Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer who
joins us from Capitol Hill for an
interview you'll see first on CBS this
morning Senator Schumer good morning
good morning we know that if Brett
Kavanaugh is confirmed this will shift
the balance of power on the Supreme
Court for decades to come
Republicans control the majority is
there anything you can do to stop this
nomination yes
well president Trump with the nomination
of Judge Cavanaugh has fulfilled or is
fulfilling two of his campaign promises
first to undo women's reproductive
freedom second to undo ACA and so I will
oppose him with everything I've got now
on these two issues when he campaigns
president Trump said he will only
appoint pro-life judges he wanted to
send Roe back to the States that means
repeal and who has vetted these judges a
preordained list of 25 preordained by
the Federalist Society and the Heritage
Foundation the Federalist Society is run
by a man named Leonard Leo whose goal in
life has been to repeal roe v wade ed
Whalen leading conservative commentators
said that no one has done more to create
a Supreme Court that would repeal Roe
then Leonard Leo he created the list
from which they chose similarly one more
point here on health care President
Trump said he wanted to repeal ACA
unlike what Justice Roberts wanted to do
and the Heritage Foundation which also
vetted this list is firmly in favor of
repealing so you put those things
together Trump what he said who he was
going to choose and the vetting of this
list these two this nominee will repeal
Roe and women's reproductive freedom PL
ACA far against what the American people
want a question please the nominee
senator when you question Brett
Kavanaugh previously for an important
appointment you asked him specifically
about Roe vs. Wade and Brett Cavanaugh
said that he believes that his binding
precedent of the court and he would
follow that it has been reaffirmed many
times so why do you believe that
abortion rights in this country are
under threat binding when you say yo for
a binding precedent that's been a trick
look what happened last week Justice
Roberts justice Gorsuch they promised
they would follow binding precedent and
they undid forty years of precedent on
labor law in the Janis case Justice
Roberts undid in one of the worst
decisions ever Citizens United reached
far back in turn overturned a hundred
years of precedent it is not good enough
for them to hide behind this Shibboleth
that will follow existing law because
when they get on the bench they change
and Leonard Leo and the Heritage
Foundation would not have put someone on
the bench who would keep roe who would
keep AC a senator in when justice
Sotomayor was up for confirmation nine
Republicans voted for Justice Kagan
there were five Republicans based on the
case you've just made about Brett
Kavanaugh hot would it be a betrayal of
the party for any Democrat to support
him in any way let me say this I believe
if we can prove to the American people
which I believe is truly the case that
this nominee will lead to a court that
repeals women's reproductive freedom
repeals ACA with its protections for
pre-existing conditions we will get a
majority of the Senate to vote for it
obviously even if we had every Democrat
we need two Republicans but if we can
make that case we will get a majority
Senator Brett Kavanaugh last night made
a point to highlight that he's hired
diverse law clerks that Elena Kagan
hired him at Harvard University we saw
Justice Kennedy surprised many with his
decisions on both sides of the aisle
what's to say that a Justice Kavanagh
won't do the same well I don't think he
would have been put on this list had he
not been one of these hard right judges
and the two issues I mentioned are
important there are several others at a
time when we have the Muller
investigation justice Cavanaugh judge
Kavanagh is way at the extremes
he believes the president shouldn't even
be investigated he has gone so far as to
say a president who believes the laws
unconstitutional doesn't have to follow
it so with the Muller situation with the
overreach of presidential power we
shouldn't put him on the bench and then
on gun rights on LGBTQ rights on
environmental rights he's way to the
right of the American people I don't
believe because he had law clerks of
some sort that that makes him any better
if president is fulfilling his campaign
promise hire to hide the most
conservative groups to come up with a
list and chose from the list the
president shouldn't have chosen from the
list and maybe they'd be far more
bipartisan support a lot of pressure on
those five red state Democrats Senator
Schumer thank you so much for joining us
we appreciate very much good to be with
you